the island of jersey is at the center of
a growing diplomatic row between the uk
and france today
both countries have now dispatched
military vessels there as the dispute
over post-brexit fishing rights
escalates more than 60 fishing boats
have been
surrounding the jersey port of saint
helia although some have been leaving in
the last few minutes
the european commission has called for
calm but says the conditions of the
post-brexit trade agreement
are not being met now french fishermen
are angry because
jersey recently published a list of 41
european boats authorized to fish in
waters around the island but
those boats need to prove that they
fished in jersey waters at least
10 times in the last three years to get
a license
the french say it is a breach of the
agreement with the eu
and now the escalating tension has led
to the deployment
of two royal navy ships and at least one
french patrol vessel
will representatives from the jersey
government and me are meeting some of
the french fishermen our defense and
security correspondent alistair bunkel
has the latest
what comes out of that meeting what has
come out of that meeting alastair well
the meeting was designed to try and have
both sides share their views and to come
to some sort of compromise that would
seem guys that would see this protest
come to an end a protest that has
achieved quite a lot of prominence
around the world i should say the eu as
you saw in my report has been
commenting on it it's also been
discussed at a press conference in
washington at the pentagon
as well but we await to see what
has come out of that meeting and whether
or not the two sides have found
some common ground or not
in the meantime the raw navy warships
remain
on station just off the coast of the
island
of jersey boris johnson who spoke to
senior jersey officials
this morning said that the royal navy
will remain there for as long
as necessary and i suspect
uh there will now be some sort of
examination of the exact wording of
post-brexit agreements
to try and find out who's in the right
and who is in the wrong here but
as i said in my report it's not the
first time that britain and france has
had
disputes over fishing rights and both
sides seem pretty entrenched
in their positions okay alastair thank
you very much